welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon and the winter soldier episode 1
has arrived on disney plus
sam wilson gave up captain america
shield saying
that belongs in a museum just to see
that shield go to the most punchable
face in the mcu
since tyler hayward no offense to either
of those actors you do such a good job
just playing someone who we
just immediately do not like too good of
a job oh yeah a little too good that's
how you know that's how you know you
cast the right guy
hey this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's official after show for the
falcon of the winter soldier i'm eric
voss here with
mt what'd you think of this episode mt
my god eric
good god literally i was just my mind
was blown like after the first 10
minutes i just had to just
pause take a second be like all right
the mcu is back proper we're getting
full-on action baby it's amazing it's so
good yeah
oh yeah and there's so much to talk
about this is our after show where we're
gonna react to the big moments and
answer the biggest wtfs you had which to
us
stands for what the
falcon oh
oh hey by the way we did see your
comments saying that we should have made
it what the buck
but trust me i did think of that but you
know written down a comment form i agree
it makes sense but
here on youtube our captions on these
videos are sometimes
automatically applied and uh what the
b buck could be accidentally translated
into something that just gets this video
immediately flagged and we don't make
any money from it and we don't notice
until hours later
so just to avoid that headache uh also
it doesn't abbreviate to wtf wtb isn't
anything
also his name is not buck it's james
buchanan barnes aka bucky no one calls a
buck
uh and also i just think what the falcon
is more fun it's a ridiculous statement
so let's just have some fun let's have
fun with it this is what the foundation
ex i agree and this is our uh this is
our after show i'm also gonna do a
separate breakdown
of all the easter eggs you missed in the
episode that's gonna come later today i
think we can get it out faster
um normally it's gonna come out the next
day this is not that video
so if an easter egg or detail is not
pointed out in this video don't comment
it i don't want to see it in the
comments and if you see someone else
commenting that
all of you have permission to shame that
person and call them a dummy
for not listening to two minutes into
the video
good lord we have to say this every time
they still don't listen
i co-sign eric i listen if you do that
you are a dummy don't be a dummy okay
don't do it don't do it don't do it so
empty here we are
six months after end game confirmed uh
sam wilson's now working freelance gigs
for the military alongside
joaquin torres a very important
character from the falcon comics and now
a very possible candidate for a future
shield possessor or someone who wants it
uh
we see falcon fighting batroc george
bettrock from uh
captain america winning soldier awesome
like he honestly bad
truck he was legit a leaper in this one
he was leaping he was
straight up late in the copter i was
like hey that's my bad that's bad
yeah boy oh bad truck leaping up again
who knows where he's gonna show up next
meanwhile bucky who has not
met with sam yet as of this first
episode uh he's trying to make amends
for his winter soldier past including
all of his leftover hydra
agents and the victims of the innocents
that he killed
so sad uh so we in this episode are
gonna talk about who these flag smashers
are because they got superpowers
where did these powers come from uh it
seemed to be the big question that was
left at the end of that episode before
this uh broadcast came up
and you know if sam told rhodey that he
was okay with giving up cap shield why
is sam now so pissed off that john
walker has it now
yeah i have a question that's a good one
eric ooh and before mt and i continue we
are happy to announce the new design for
the latest obsession number three shirt
from new rockstars and our merch
partners at epic hero
it is this amazing looking falcon in the
winter soldier inspired design
especially from those glorious
in credits so filled with easter eggs
just like this shirt
it's pure anarchy or in this case
anarchy
assembled now as always these are
limited edition collectibles so once
they sell out
back in the blue dungeon they go you
gotta get your hands on these fast
you can get them at new
rockstarsmerch.com and when you do
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will appear on
screen during our inside marvel falcon
the winner soldier after shows
we don't have any yet because no one has
bothered me but i can't wait to see what
you guys write for next week's episode
but in the meantime epic hero shop just
launched a new youtube channel
epic hero labs and we are celebrating
that with some
giveaways of 10 sony playstation 5s
disc editions we've already given away
one of those and the other nine are
burning holes in our pockets we got very
very big pockets that could fit
ps5s in them uh it's it's like 2002
um cargo pants are back in full
of our ps5 so we are begging you take
these off our hands all you got to do is
subscribe to the youtube channel to
enter to win one
and we are giving away one ps5 for every
10 thousand subscribers on the road to
one hundred thousand so to enter to win
the next one just subscribe to epic gear
labs on youtube then go to
epicureshop.com
giveaway to share your information plus
see a bunch more ways to get extra
entries into that
giveaway it's a free ps5 you gotta
you're losing a chance to have fun
gaming times
all right mt what is our first what the
falcon what the falc or who the falcon
anyway
are the flag smashers yeah the flag
smashers
have this version of them that are in
the mcu but in the comics they're they
appear to be based on there's one guy
named flag smasher
named carl morgenthau uh he's a captain
america villain
and he his goal is to kind of erase all
political divisions
smash those flags
and it kind of leads this terrorist
network uh and as is pointed out in this
show
the goals are kind of the same here but
here it's a military group
uh and it kind of emerged from the blip
and they
kind of liked it that way they liked a
world without borders without uh
infighting between countries
they're all just kind of miserable
together what's wrong with that
i mean yeah and like i i i really like
how they're setting them up to be like
this like these
freedom fighters of the people of sorts
and like i don't know like
as you can see like in the show like
they have like a network of like you
know
people that are like they message like
meet up in a place and like
um just so they can make their crimes
easier
to pull off which is very smart you're
just sort of crowd sourcing
right crowdsourcing terrorism v flash
mob
right yeah flash mob terrorism it's the
way of the future let's do it
many of us consider flash mobs to be a
form of terrorism i
didn't have to be sung at them all food
court get out of here
honestly it 100 is and uh it's just very
uncomfortable
so let's just stop doing that that's
just in general that's the
best thing about quarantine it's less
flash
uh now here in the show uh it's being
headed up by aaron kelemen's character
who is confirmed in the credits of this
episode to be named carly morgantho so
they are bringing in that connection
but what's weird about this group is
they have powers
they are super agile super strong
they can jump out of a swiss bank second
stories
and land without breaking those ankles
uh we've seen from trailer footage that
uh eric kellerman's character can like
jump real high she can leap
from one truck to another in a single
bound and that was kind of the question
set up at the very end taurus asked sam
do you
think he could be uh insane's like shut
up
shut up it's only episode one there's
too many details we just can't talk
don't you know the viewers are watching
us right now come on
man yeah like they're crazy super
powered like
i think they even like like remember
that part when he like kicked that guy
into like the pole and like that guy
100 paralyzed that is okay very nice
he's gonna need those roadie braces to
walk
[Laughter]
but yeah no like these guys are
obviously just augmented in some way we
don't know exactly how
uh we don't know if they're making like
if someone's out there making super
soldiers someone out there making like
you know
like cyborg type people we just know
that these people um
have the juice to pull off their agenda
and
yeah they seem very they got the juice
they got the juice
uh the uh next it might be next episode
but we know from a promo clip that
sam is kind of debating are they aliens
androids or wizards and they're not
magic so they're not wizards
they could be androids they could be you
know cybernetically enhanced
uh they're probably not aliens though i
mean let's let's try to
sort who these people are i made a video
where uh arguing that they're either
super soldiers or mutants
super soldiers being like well we know
the winter soldier program was using
that super soldier serum there could be
other batches of it out there
uh the mutant argument is that after the
events of endgame that you know
um for millennia there has been a
dormant
mutant gene and certain people of the
population that now
with all these extraterrestrial threats
it's now just evolving to be activated
to make uh humankind more fit for
survival in a broader universe
um it might be too soon for mutants
super soldiers seems like a way it could
go
could we be looking at scrolls could we
look be looking at inhumans
what do you think i mean like okay so in
terms of aliens here's a really
interesting idea that i was thinking
about earlier
i was thinking that so remember and far
from home that um
what's it called nick fury mentions that
there are cree sleeper cells
somewhere around on marvel earth the mcu
so maybe and i don't know but we could
be looking at some
sleeper cell stuff possibly i like that
idea
[ __ ] winter soldier does take place
before spider-man far from home as far
as i believe if i'm not mistaken
that's right it takes place i think two
or three months before
yes it would be yeah so we still haven't
seen those cree sleeper cells yet that
could still come in place so
you know and what's great about that is
uh cree
are um they're supposed to be different
colors but like there's
pink skinned cree that you know in the
mcu according
to uh to jude law's character is just
normal
you know white human caucasian human
being so
uh
so presumably they could be though there
was this other trailer footage where
aaron kellerman's character
felt like kind of an outcast it almost
kind of reminded me of like
he's some kind of underground mutant
group like morlocks or something like
that but oh yeah
it could it could potentially be that
because yeah the morlocks were
were pretty uh like low-key underground
and
they moved from the shadows sort of but
yeah they were they were kind of like
sewer dwellers like the ninja turtles
but they
they didn't have these like political
ambitions that's more connected to maybe
like the mutant brotherhood or something
like that but the brotherhood
of mutants would kind of want their own
country they wouldn't want all the
world's united
uh they'd kind of want just let us have
genocide and leave us a hell alone
please
so i don't uh i think this could be some
kind of new thing we were talking about
how
uh based off of the character walking
tourists who we're gonna talk about in a
bit
uh in the comics he has been
experimented by a guy named carl malus
who does a lot of human experimentation
and that
maybe carl malus could be behind this
and is kind of experimenting doing some
uh
advanced uh biotech weaponry
kind of stuff on people to weaponize
them and that these people were escapees
and now they have these
this kind of political agenda it's kind
of hard to reconcile the political
agenda with their superhuman skills
it's kind of like a hat on a hat it's
like well which is going to be the more
important identifier of these characters
no for sure like karl males has been
like someone that i've been uh
really thinking about um ever since i
watched the episode because
because of uh joaquim taurus and like
he's this guy who
who likes to just you know experiment on
people try to give them
powers in this weird way so maybe um
potentially uh these uh flag smashers
uh could be in league or or have been
augmented with uh carl melts but we
haven't
there hasn't been any sign of males
quite yet yeah but we're not on the
malice trade we're not on the malice
trade but like
carl malus is someone that is very
significant in um
yes uh and joaquin tours his life so we
yeah
we gotta keep an eye on him we gotta
keep it up you know empty maybe the
answer is in their symbol they have this
red hand print
and then now we see it's like over a
world that was the uh ar
thing on torius's phone he's like oh you
gotta you gotta pay attention to these
guys
so is there something like they just
rather than having uh
flags identify the different regions of
the world just one hand
that uniques or that uniquely ties them
all together
and people pointed this out when we
first saw them in the trailer months ago
that like that red hand is it just the
hand are they going to be
merging those two things i don't know
the hand are ninjas
right so probably not that version of
the hand yeah i wouldn't suspect the
hand in this at all i think the hand
is a very specific um you know part of
the marvel universe that
this doesn't seem to be touching on so
yeah i wouldn't put a factor in the hand
here
but the hand in the world symbol is is a
very interesting symbol
and i honestly personally i think it
could be just pointing out to you
hey let's just be one world let's just
uh you know
hold hands in a way like let's just keep
our hand like
obviously they're like a militant group
and they're
radical and like obviously you know
they're very violent but
like their their main goal is just like
all right let's just forget the borders
it's all about humanity and um and like
us
coming together so i get the symbol but
like obviously there could be a deeper
meaning to all that
yeah and they may be tied with uh with
zemo's plan zemo did not show up in this
episode
so we don't really know what zemo's
whole goal or mission or
what his whole plot is yet so they could
be uh connected to him
but let's look at what they did this
episode they did a flash mob and we'll
use that to create a diversion to rob
this bank in switzerland now i think
this is important because swiss banks
have the reputation of storing money
offshore money for criminals
and i wonder if that could be how we get
to mag report magipor has the world's
criminal elite there maybe they do their
banking
with the swiss bank and these guys are
trying to piss off some super criminal
or get money for the super criminal
by ripping off some other criminal joker
and dark knight style
uh like from this swiss bank and that's
how it's connected that is an excellent
link eric that's literally like
because like you're exactly right swiss
banks are like the perfect banks for
people that do sketchy stuff so like
either it's
criminals or like you know probably like
sketchy politicians who have like you
know
money on the side it's literally the
perfect mark for
an organization like um the flag
smashers
so yeah like i it is like once i saw
that they were breaking into a bank i
was like you know what
that's very smart that's like they got
some whoever's in charge of the flags
masters they're very very
like um deliberate in their actions it
seems and
yeah like a lot of organization so like
it would be very interesting if it was
just
carly um morgenthau um behind all of
this because like it would be great to
see like
you know we'll have zemo and then we'll
have carly like these two amazing minds
just like you know as factors for uh
bucky and sam to deal with
but uh yeah these black smashers are um
definitely an organized force and i i
definitely don't think they're their
hand or anything
no yeah agreed now they did have this
thing where i assume it was cash or it
was just money or gold bars in those
bags but they always do this thing in
movies where they have big duffel bags
filled with cash
those would be so hard to carry just one
of those
it's like several hundreds pounds two
kids oh yeah like you would you would
definitely have to hit the gym
like yeah but this guy's super strong so
it justifies it good job bucker winter
soldier
um whereas the physics of can you um
do a tandem wingsuit jump with like
another fully grown man and still be
able to glide down
safely i don't know if you could do that
point break style
i i couldn't just do it with myself
there because i'm a very large man
i would just sink to the bottom the
wings wouldn't activate and the wings
would just
snap off really it's like oh good god
this man is too big
uh wow i'm so sorry
let's go so you know who else is from
switzerland empty oh yes i do my friend
hey hey we all that zola cola bro
we back on the solar train you didn't
know we were on the zone
[Laughter]
hey i'm just bringing it up you never
know in those bags it didn't
necessarily have to be cash to fund a
criminal enterprise it could have been
important weird artifacts that a certain
ai
would have in some family bank back in
switzerland
probably not probably not worried you
never know hey here's another wild zola
theory
zola was a small man maybe zola was in
one of those bags maybe they just shoved
them in
maybe there's two zolas one was all up
her bag
it's like we got him we got zola back he
we stored him in the bank and we got him
he did not die he's a very old shriveled
tiny swiss man
played by toby jones who's the only
those duffel bags this is the
corpse of zolas very important for them
to get it yeah
for now i'm just gonna say i think uh
the these flag smashers
it's not as important how they got their
powers it's what they believe
and i think that belief lends itself to
being they're more likely to be super
soldiers or something again maybe not
necessarily super soldier serum
the same cocktail that like bucky and
steve got but something like that maybe
someone like carl malus or someone
weaponizing these people and then they
were bitter from that experience
and then collectively they realized you
know what you can't trust any world
government
you kind of or you know what you can't
trust any national government if they're
going to be at war with each other let's
just do away with that and be kind of
anarchists
i mean you know i i understand with the
frustration with
uh local government but like let's just
uh let's tone it down with the violence
uh
you know you don't need to you don't
need to arrange these flash mobs guys
come on you really don't and
like they really stomp the [ __ ] out of
uh
oh boy torres yeah they really did poor
guy
he was his yeah his eye was not
fantastic he'll be he'll be okay
uh we're gonna talk more about taurus
and uh the rest of the questions you
have from the show but first we want to
thank some people who helped us make it
starting with our friends at bombas
thank you to bombas for sponsoring this
episode bombas
makes the most comfortable socks in the
history of feet i'm actually
wearing them right now oh [ __ ] i don't
know if you can see that oh
these are babas they're so comfortable
are we trying to appeal it to the foot
audience
is that what we're doing is just trump
i'm not taking off my bombas i'm not
this isn't that kind of channel
yes we'll we're willing to go there if
you join until we get really desperate
we'll save this feat picks for the
patreon um
hey but we're thinking bombas right now
right uh
bombas has rethought every little detail
of socks to make them way more
comfortable i wear them every day i'm a
huge fan
they make the really short no sea socks
in a way that they don't slide down
inside your shoes which i hate when that
happens
uh i'm not sure how bombers did this but
they nailed it uh
and uh these socks do more than keep
your feet cozy of course they help give
back to the most vulnerable members of
our community because
for every pair of socks that you
purchase from baba's bombas donates a
pair to someone in need that's amazing
ah it's so nice i love it when we can
partner with uh with
sponsors like this the generosity of
bomba's customers has allowed them to
donate over 40 million pairs of socks
and counting through their nationwide
network
of over 3 000 giving partners and the
impact is more powerful than ever to
those experiencing homelessness
these socks represent the dignity of
putting on clean clothes a small comfort
that's especially important right now
so give a pair when you buy a pair and
get 20 off your first purchase of bombus
at bombas.com marvel that's b o
m b a s dot com slash marvel for twenty
percent off your first purchase
bombus.com marvel we also wanna thank
our friends at magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode
right now i am trying to eat better but
a healthy breakfast does not have to be
boring
magic spoon has the amazing flavors you
love but without all the bad stuff
every serving has zero grams of sugar
and at least 13 grams of protein and
only four net grams of carbs
only 140 calories a serving it's
keto-friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb and gmo free
get yourself a variety pack of cocoa
fruity frosted and peanut butter flavors
go to magicspoon.com marvel to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code of
marvel at checkout
to save five dollars off your order and
magic spoon is so confident in their
product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason the refund your money no
questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
marvel and use the code marvel to save
five dollars off thank you to magic
spoon for sponsoring this video
and our friends at stereo thank you to
stereo for sponsoring us
depending on whether you're watching
this you might be able to jump into the
stereo app and share your thoughts on
this episode with us
every friday morning we go live on
stereo app with inside marvel stereo is
the free live podcasting platform where
you can interact with us
in real time sending us voice messages
that we will air and respond to
live so we were able to get this episode
of inside marvel out early but
mt and i are going to be doing a q a
trying to answer all of your questions
live 9 a.m pacific time noon eastern
time
friday morning this week and then uh
every week there forward
you're going to get an earlier version
of this inside marvel show live at 9 00
a.m so download the stereo app for free
by going to stereo.com
new rockstars oh in this uh special
bonus q a segment we do exclusive with
our stereo listeners that actually goes
up on our youtube channel on sunday so
you're gonna be a star
if you join us on stereo earth also you
can listen to all of our older episodes
or to the other
weekly new rockstar shows on stereo by
following our account on stereo every
thursday evening off screen producer
zach and brandon are doing a falcon
winter soldier pre-show
where they make a lot of predictions
that probably won't come true i'm with
them on there i get it it's fun it's
hard and they don't deal with the
consequences the next morning
good for them so we'll see you on stereo
uh but empty
our next what the falcon i want to hear
your thoughts on this
uh who the falcon is this replacement
cap
played by white russell at the end of
episode the episode
uh an abomination eric i couldn't even
believe it i
was just so i mean i knew it was coming
i knew it was coming but like the
disrespect
eric the disrespect to sandra was just
so
just it made me enraged i
snapped my keyboard in two i took a walk
um
i yelled at my neighbors it was just a
really terrible thing just kidding it's
all false
no that's a good question this is us
agent john walker played
by wyatt russell and basically he's this
wannabe cap this was
in like he i believe he plays the super
patriot in the comics
yeah he goes by a couple of her names he
like starts as like a wrestler and then
there's like a vacancy and he's like hey
let's start a vigilante group
i'll be super patriot and then it kind
of works he kind of becomes a
replacement cap for a short time but
yeah but like here's the question though
why why did the government official that
government official tells sam
it was the right decision to give up the
shield just to give it to john walker
like that's right
that's my it's messed up it's messed up
i have a conspiracy theory about this i
think it's supposed to be about
everything but empty about this in
particular
so there was that moment where uh where
taurus is like hey you should rewrite
that in the gear and sam's like could
you not
he's like i'm sorry it's just every time
ops messes with my gear
it's something messes up i am wondering
if the government is sabotaging sam
wilson they want him to drop out of the
sky and die
so when he hands over the shield they're
like oh great we don't have to look like
bad guys when something
bad happens and he's not the next cap
he's just falcon
i think they're still mad at falcon for
joining team cap
during the sokovia accords thunderbolt
ross is still out there he's secretary
of state we think
he's probably still pissed off and i
think all these government officials
want sam to fail and they are setting
him up bro
that's good that's good as a guy i
didn't even consider that you know
that's
maybe because they could easily because
like that's the best way to get rid of
sam it's like if we just mess with his
tech
he's flying off like all over canyons
and [ __ ] just have him just fail
die just like riley well riley got shot
down r.i.p harley sorry or did he get
shot down or was he set up
was he murdered oh my god who knows
now you got me thinking about this
government conspiracy god dang eric
you're a goddamn goes all the way to the
top empty i'm telling you
oh there's a microphone here so it's
blocked out all the way to the top
where's my face i am dusting no
[Laughter]
i'm back i'm back but yeah
no that's a good point that he could
easily be getting sabotaged i didn't
even consider that i think at the end of
the day whether or not that's true the
government does not want sam to be the
bearer of the shield they don't want to
be at war with sam because he's still a
popular avenger
but they want their own guy to be cap it
was so annoying that they had them stick
to those talking
points uh we need new heroes just so
they can parrot it back and say well as
as sam wilson said we do need new heroes
so we're going to get one who looks
exactly
like chris evans pretty much and can
just be a
you know milk toast wonder bread captain
america
every time i see um you know this this
fake cap u.s agent
i think uh will shuster uh from glee
like the actor's name is the teacher
from glee because like he just
look i cannot get that out of my head he
has a similar smile yeah
yeah like bottom half of like his face
like with the mask on i'm like
here you will shuster like yeah evil
will shuster
cannot stand you yeah yeah yeah he's
gonna make everyone
sit in a weird uh glee club room and
just sing for each other
which is all that show became after a
while so i'm gonna cheer you up with a
song that's gonna be a cover of
fireworks by katy perry
right i like to call this one the
national anthem
[Music]
it was just like everyone's always on no
no it's another flash mob
damn it i'm being terrorized stop it
stop enough with the flash mobs we're
good uh we should say this is one of our
few legacy actors in the mcu his father
kurt russell played
our lord in heaven ego the living planet
hey rest in peace you evil bastard
i mean kurt russell's still alive we
should be clear oh yeah not not not
russell ego yeah kurt russell's an
amazing person
so but uh what is our next that's kind
of related because there's a vacancy
uh for captain america so what's our
next what the falcon i mean
this is a good question where the falcon
is old cap anyway
speaking of conspiracy theories uh it
was so interesting how joaquin torres
was like
you know i just read these conspiracy
theories saying that captain america is
on a secret moon base looking down on us
i guess is that kind of like a dr
manhattan thing like we think he's on
mars and he's kind of like looking down
at us
he left we don't know where he went uh
but like
the crazy thing about this is like that
could be kind of
true empty we know we got sword there's
that peak space station where nick fury
is up in space
could that be where old catboy at the
end i mean
it's it's quite possible because like if
you're just a like a regular person in
the mcu
you don't know what like what's going on
with sword you just see people getting
shot into space
and all that's like you're just like
what what are they go what is going on
yeah
they got obviously they got thanos on
the mind with like they have an alien
invasion that just happened
so it's just like they everybody's eyes
are upward so like i wouldn't be
surprised if they saw
you know rockets being sent into space
or like you know some space stuff going
on and be like well yeah
cap's gone so like maybe cap went into
space
like who does yes agreed uh and like at
the end of one division that squirrel
met with monica rambo and was like
there's someone up there who wants to
meet with you and we all assumed oh just
nick fury because nick fury's up with
scrolls on that space station
apart from home post credit scene but
maybe old cap could be part of that too
now look we're not expecting to see
an old man chris evans show up in the
show uh even kevin feige recently was
like hey those rumors that he's gonna be
in two more movies
those are not confirmed uh so yeah this
i i
really doubt chris evans is gonna show
up in the show beyond like a flashback
or
audio echoing back or something like
that but just kind of answering that for
the broader mcu
clearly the show is setting up this
question of where chris evans old man
cap went
uh they're not just gonna say oh he died
off or he just disappeared
he is somewhere in the show and i think
taurus really wants to know
i think he actually wants to know
because he is pissed off at the avengers
he's part of this conspiracy
that's my yes he's like where's cap
where are you hiding him
and like you know like in they
specifically did not say that he was
dead
like that's something that we should
probably just just gone bring to attack
yeah just like they were like he's gone
and like you know gone can mean a lot of
things
but like they specifically say gone so
like
he could be on the moon maybe the
avengers just didn't tell
them about old cap in general for sure
yeah oh
he went to the quantum realm and then he
just never came back and so now he's
gone but like he's secretly just you
know
playing bingo and uh marmalade on his
own oh yeah
you know mt i was i'm working on the
breakdown right now and uh i was going
through
those exhibits in the smithsonian they
updated it for the events of uh
civil war end game and infinity war and
if you look closely it just mentioned
just kind of vaguely
uh steve rogers disappeared and i think
people don't know
that he came back as an old man for sure
they don't know what happened to him in
that battle for all they know he just
kind of disappeared on this mission to
save everyone
and they're grateful for that but as far
as they know he's just gone
poof vanished and he was one of the
people who kind of traded his life so
that everyone else could come back
so yeah uh but i think this idea is that
sam knows where cap is
and uh he's not telling oh yeah cause
like uh when uh when
taurus was asking him hey where are you
headed he was like yeah we're just gonna
do some moon stuff but like he was
smiling so i was like
all right so this doesn't feel like a
somber thing
that he's i mean obviously he's giving
up the shield and he's not happy about
it yeah but like it didn't feel like a
all right my buddy is dead and like i
have to go
do this thing it just felt like a all
right this is just something i got to do
and you know it's just
so like i i definitely do think that
there's a there's something that we
don't know about
cap out there but i want to ask umt who
the falcon is joaquin torres
this isn't just a random dude who's a
friend of a falcon in this show
this name is important to marvel comics
and could be very important in marvel's
future so tell us about this guy
oh yeah this is a very significant this
is just not your just ordinary
the soldier guy uh joaquin torres is
actually
in the comics falcon um who he takes
over the role as falcon when
sam wilson becomes captain america and
uh joachim torres is very
um interesting because he had undergone
he was kidnapped and then he had
undergone genetic experiments
by dr carl malus and um
it's really weird in the comics they
infused his dna with that of red wing
the actual bird like in the comics he
was an actual bird and not an ai
and so um he was basically this bird man
and he could literally
fly and like you know he had bird powers
and he had a telepathic
link to red wing and so which is why
um mere and eric are just like we have
our malice feelers up
um because malice he um he's obsessed
with making super human people
so if um if malice is directly linked to
joaquin torrens and joaquin towards his
um
origins there could be a possibility
maybe
that he could be in the show down the
line but yeah we haven't seen anything
of him yet
but uh it's he's a very important figure
in um
towards falcon's backstory and as well
spider woman
that's right yeah jessica drew is
connected to malice as well uh the
taurus i think it's just interesting
because he is uh it gives us another
option of who could bury the shield at
the end of the series
or it makes it more even more possible
for sam to bear the shield
because now we have someone to take over
falcon but you know right now i don't
totally trust
uh torres because he seemed a little
eager to to mess around with that tech
seemed a little eager to like you know
put sam on instagram live in that moment
uh that's true i don't trust him yet i
obviously i'm suspicious of everyone
but i wonder if he's gonna be like the
government's pick to take over falcon
after they ask sam that would be
interesting
that would be really interesting maybe
you're right not to trust him because he
was being sketchy with that he wasn't i
was wondering
it was like he was he was filming
everything i'm like why are you doing
that
yeah aren't you supposed to be working
yeah and he seemed to be kind of like
testing sam a little bit he's like oh
you can speak arabic
okay noted noted
no dead interesting now you're turning
me into a conspiracy like a harder
conspiracy theorist now
get that one and make a hat
[Laughter]
we are on the moon they're all on the
moon empty
that's why there was no avengers in the
far from home because they were all the
moon
they're all moon people
[Laughter]
but no yes so yeah taurus is going to be
a really big part of
bsu i'm assuming moving forward i
honestly think that he could actually
end up being
if he isn't you know an evil son of a
[ __ ] um
he could actually end up being uh on the
young avengers as okay yeah so i mean
he's a younger
idea yeah young adventurers would have
to move on from being like teenagers to
being like yeah
mid-20s like he's like younger people
avengers obviously
not like teenagers yeah yeah let's talk
about bucky's list
who the falcon is on bucky's list how
important is this gonna be
is this show i'm just gonna be like my
name is bucky and i'm making amends now
i mean um there's there was one person
on bucky's list that really caught my
eye and he's right on the very top
rostov
i don't know how to pronounce that and i
believe that this is a an easter egg or
something that is pointing to the
existence of
an mcu red barbarian now red barbarian
was a uh character in the comics who
used to be
who had a like who's he was a spy master
and
he had a large network of spies and he
just sent them out and at one point he
sold these codes called the zephyr codes
on the black market which were these
codes that activated
these super soldiered people um and and
sent them on various missions that they
assumed were
part of you know helping russia but was
actually you know
wherever whatever um whoever bought them
had them
doing so red barbarian um he could be
a a very big factor in um the winter
soldier's past because
who knows how many people the winter
soldier has worked with closely
in the past so we could see rostov being
a hydra member
um oh yeah potentially so who knows it
could be anything
yeah uh he could just be one of these uh
rogue uh broker figures you know
who he has just made a lot of deals of
the devil in the past and he
like has sold weapons to these people
he's sold uh you know
uh informants lists he's just kind of
like made money and he's just serving
himself
and now bucky's like that guy needs to
go or needs to be apologized to maybe
bucky just like
accidentally you know ran over his
mailbox and he's like look
my name is uh bucky barnes i'm not the
winner soldier anymore but i ran over
your mailbox and that's technically a
federal crime
so i have to apologize for it uh also
i've bugged your house and i'm listening
to everything you say you son of a [ __ ]
yeah i don't know
it's like oops you know just common
mistakes everyone does it just
casual bugging of your house and yeah
running over your mailbox
yeah common mistake until we get there
though i'm wondering if there's gonna be
more with this uh yori nakajima
and his son you know or leah the
waitress he met like
there might be more uh to that thread to
pull this guy
was just kind of in the wrong place at
the wrong time and i wonder if like
that will lead us to mag report or
something like that like there's more to
this
you know what what what bucky did there
and what that mission was and
uh maybe make it up to yori he has to go
explore that i mean
potential but it could be that but it
could also be you know hydra is all
about
you know getting rid of the right
dominoes so that they
their um their agenda could be pushed
forward right and that was all
like what project insight was all about
that's what zola
was all about he was just like just find
the right people to eliminate all that
stuff as we saw in um
in winter soldier yeah so i think that
this this person just could be
some somebody that was a threat to hydra
or some
somebody that hydra just needed out of
the way completely
um so they're just like just get rid of
this kid but i'm very interested to see
why he was assassinated
and what this kid's link is to the
overall show if there is
i mean the poor kid obviously just it
seemed like he would just witness that
thing at the time i just want to know
what that dude was
and like what was really going on there
uh i think there's
more i i maybe this is just one of many
things we'll see over the course of the
series of other past horrible incidents
that happen but we should talk about bad
truck what the falcon was bad trucks
plan
and what's his next move because we
aren't done with him we know from
trailer footage this guy's going to come
back he's going to be in other
scenes other fights with them so what do
you think this is mt like what's batroc
doing
honestly bro i honestly it's such a good
question because like i just don't know
what he's up to yeah yeah they seem to
be
well in the context of that scene they
were hijacking this plane to try to get
his air force captain they hijacked the
plane and they were taking it into
libyan airspace
so what was going on there why did they
need this captain in particular were
they just trying to
if they're just trying to capture an
american gi or an american soldier
there'd be so many easier ways to do it
if they're just trying to get a hostage
for
a hostile government um rohde kind of
alluded the fact that treaties were
being torn up so maybe there's some kind
of like
you know wore a brewing between the
nation so they were trying to like
steal a prisoner who would have been
valuable to trade back for a prisoner of
war
from their side but it seemed like bad
trucks seems like a kind of guy who's
like
stealing uh soldiers for governments to
trade to hostile rogue nations
um but it just seemed like kind of a
weird plan i don't know exactly what bad
trucks up to but like
it it has to tie to the overall store
yeah um i'm assuming
it's very interesting and like they seem
to be very invested in uh
in taking this map yeah and and this guy
was like they
already hijacked the plane before the
before the air force before torres knew
that's why i think this whole plan was
weird that they had sam they're like
yeah they got
this has to be subtle this has to be
private i think it was all a setup for
sam i think they wanted sam to die there
and there was they were all in on it
like batroc was hired by
the the government to take out sam
because otherwise the plan doesn't make
any sense
it could have just been weird writing
look i've fallen down this rabbit hole
before where it's like
i find weird little inconsistencies in
the writing i think it's evidence of
something
i don't know i do it all could be
nothing i literally my entire twitter
feed is just that
at the end of the day uh batroc is
coming back
and i think he's gonna be key to sam and
bucky understanding what's really afoot
here
uh i don't know if this is evidence of
uh of sam being set up but i do at the
end of the day think sam is being set up
to fail
i think that poor guy is in over his
head oh yeah for sure yeah
yeah um there's a lot of people out
there that just don't want sam to
succeed right
um but let's close out with our uh
weekly segment of oh cat my cap
so yeah we're gonna run through the
various potential cap successors uh the
potential heirs to the shield
and uh we're gonna rank them either
that's my cap or
not my cap so i've gotta got my cap cap
on here
who gets the cap cap i always look
stupid if anyone needs a cap it's my
bald ass dude so i should probably get a
cat
for the next one yeah we'll get you a
cat nice uh
all right so uh let's start with our boy
sam wilson
uh that's my cap or not my cap empty you
already know eric that's mine that's my
captain he's the best
we love that guy feeding the homeless
trying to help his sister get her boat
from underwater
not literally you know what a good
financial he tried his best he tried his
best
that loan officers they're always
villains it's the banks you know
it makes you want to rob a swisher it
really does don't you feel that way it
really does
um let's talk about bucky barnes uh this
episode uh that's my capper not my cat
i mean you know bucky he's he's still
he's still learning
about being you know a nice a nice boy
and like you know
well he was um working with um his
therapist to try to better himself but
he
he's not a hundred percent there yet so
let's just say not my cap
yeah um quite yet because obviously this
is a story about falcon yeah
but i'm going to say not my captain he's
still got something he's got something
we're going to do but i'm going to
give him uh that's my cap just to see
bucky be polite and have to smile
i'm like that's some boy scout [ __ ]
right there good for you
you're so right because it was so
awkward he's so uncomfortable
yeah he really is um all right u.s agent
john walker or just john walker
not my cap that raggedy man i
i've been kind of mean to him he might
be a really nice guy we'll see
maybe next episode but not my cat maybe
i mean yeah the actor
i'm sure he's a very nice russell's
great but uh yeah um
okay joaquin torres didn't think he'd be
on our list last week but
now he is what do you think him too i
mean i mean i don't think he'll be my
cap i don't think he'll end up being cap
specifically but
i think that he's a if he ends up being
a nice
man that isn't like you know corrupt i
think he's a good dude i think he has a
good
heart from what we from what we know now
and so
potentially maybe he would make a good
cop but i'm going to say not my cat
because i don't think he'll be
yeah i'll say maybe that's my falcon but
so far he's given me more reasons to
suspect him he took a beating i feel bad
for him when he got
beat up there he got his ass beat he got
stomped
yeah so right now i'm gonna say not my
cat maybe my falcon
well let us know your thoughts on this
episode i'm gonna go back to working on
the breakdown where hopefully we'll be
able to get it out later today
uh and uh just a note for everyone we
were able to get this out early because
luckily and this almost never happened
starting to happen more and more
uh we were able to get early access to
watch the episode that's
amazing um thank you to disney plus and
everyone
on there for helping us out here uh but
next week we're going back to our normal
schedule so that means
inside marvel will come out early
afternoon pacific time
uh on fridays and our breakdown is
coming out on saturdays we don't have
an early 24 hours to work on it this
time sorry
but saturday's the fastest way to get it
to you guys and keep that quality
that we're doing so uh stay tuned for
that that will be for episode two
episode one get too fast but that is it
for this episode of inside marvel
the after show of falcon winter soldier
mt
thank you so much you've been wonderful
obviously man you know i love making
videos with you dog
you know this is my job oh it's my jam
too you're my jelly
we'll be back next friday for our
reaction episode two and our after show
which mt will answer all of your big
what the falcons and a reminder to
download the stereo app by going to
stereo.com
new rockstar so you can listen to our
weekly live shows submit questions and
theories and heroes respond in real time
download the app for free on apple and
android and create an avatar and profile
follow mt at mastertainment follow me at
ea boss follow new rockstar subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast thank you for watching and we
will close out with our favorite moment
of the episode
how old are you 106.
[Music]
[Music]
you